[Music]
well the nhl is moving out of the
self-quarantine phase by releasing its
phase ii protocol sports director chris
matthews joining us live in studio with
some of the details
from that 21-page document chris well
thank you brian yeah the nhl is taking
every step necessary to allow the league
to resume with its postseason
this phase ii release is voluntary and
according to government restrictions in
each market
will include player participation at
training facilities by early june
now they are taking this very seriously
even the first page says this protocol
while very comprehensive
cannot mitigate all risk going on to say
a range of clinical scenarios exist
from very mild to fatal outcome a few of
the details from the 21 page release
indicates players
may return to facilities in small groups
of six
and clubs are not permitted to require
players to return to their club's
home city to participate no coaches
allowed
testing will be done 48 hours in advance
of a player returning to its facility
but testing will be done will not be
done we should say
if it takes away or deprives healthcare
workers vulnerable populations and
symptomatic individuals
from necessary diagnostic testing now to
give you an idea how seriously the
league is taking this
supplements will come in a single
dispense packet there are two boxes of
tissue for each bench
no meals at the facilities and players
must must wear masks
entering or leaving those training
facilities brian one more thing
pretty fired up about wednesday all
raiders all the time right here on
channel 8 back over to you chris